in terms of using
uh kohler engines what's what's an
interesting difference between a
propulsion of a rocket
from earth once you're standing in the
ground to orbit
and then the kind of propulsion
necessary for once you get out
or better to like deep space to
to move around yes the reason
you can't use an engine like mine
to get off the ground is
you know the thrust it generates is
instantaneous thrust is very small but
if you
if you have the time and and can
accumulate that acceleration you can
still reach speeds that are
very interesting for exploration and and
even for missions with
humans on them an interesting
direction i think we need to go as as
humans exploring space is um the power
supplies for electric propulsion are
are limiting us in that
you know solar panels are really
inefficient and bulky and
batteries i don't know when anybody's
ever going to
improve battery technology i know a lot
of people that work on that
and nuclear power
you we could have a lot more powerful
electric propulsion system so they would
be
extremely fuel efficient but more
instantaneous for us to do more
interesting missions
if we could start launching more nuclear
systems but
so like something that's powered nuclear
that's right way to say it yeah
but is it a small enough container that
could be launched
yeah so um i mean as a world we do
launch um spacecraft with nuclear power
systems on board but size is is one
consideration it hasn't been a big focus
so the
the reactors and the heaters and
everything are
bulky and so they're really only
suitable for some of the much bigger
interplanetary stuff
um so that's one issue but then it's a
whole like
rat's nest of political stuff as well
i i heard uh i think elon described or
somebody
i think i think it was elon to describe
the uh eevee tall like
electrical um vertical take off and
landing vehicles so basically saying
rockets
i'm obviously elon is interested in
electric vehicles right but he said that
rockets
uh in the in the near term it doesn't
make sense for them to be electrical
uh what do you see a world with the
rockets
that we use to get into orbit are also
electric based uh it's possible you can
produce the thrust levels you need but
you need this
uh a much bigger power supply and i
think that would be nuclear
and the only way people have been able
to launch them at all is that they're in
a
you know 100 times redundancy safe mode
while they're being launched and they're
not turned on until they're farther off
so if you were to
actually try to use it on launch i think
a lot of people
would still have an issue with that but
someday it's a it's an interesting
concept
nuclear it seems like people like
everybody that works on nuclear power
has shown how safe it is as a source of
language
and uh and yet we are seem to be
i mean based on the history based on the
excellent hbo
series russian with the chernobyl it
seems like we have
our risk estimation about this
particular power source is uh
drastically inaccurate but that's that's
a fascinating idea that we would
use nuclear as a source for our vehicles
uh and not just in outer space that's
cool i'm going to look into that
that's super interesting well um just
last year
trump eased up a little bit on the
regulations
and nasa and hopefully others are
they're starting to pick up on the
development so
now is a good time to look into it
because there's actually some movement
is that a hope for you to to explore
different energy sources
that the entirety of the vehicle uses
something
like uh like the entirety of the
propulsion systems for all aspects of
the vehicles
life travel is the same or electric
is it possible for it to be the same
like the corloid engine being used
for everything you could and you would
have to do it in the same way
we do different stages of rockets now
where once you've
used up an engine
or a stage you let it go because there's
really no point in holding on to it so i
wouldn't necessarily want to use
the the same engine for the whole thing
but the same technology i think would be
interesting
okay so it's possible all right but uh
yeah
it turns down to the power source the
power source it's really
you